[Music]
finishing on yawn oh i want to finish in
peace
wow you really enjoy your yawn yeah it
was good see i got like slight water
guys
that's how i wear my farts and that's
going to be included in
the video oh really okay i thought it
was mid action you sniff your own fart
leave it in there fine i'm confident i
try to run from it
your favorite yeah like a big mistake
yeah do you ever try to like
try to be like conscious of the person
next to you so then even though you
fought you're like
you try to breathe it back in like a
vacuum you're like vacuum it all in then
you just like walk away or hold it
yeah but then you are like you know if i
fart right now and then like invisible
green rays are coming over here i'm like
no so i'm saying why even release the
invisible green rays
what if he farted and you walk into his
space okay that's different oh
i'm no but he's saying like you know but
there are times in in life where you
forget that people around you
well that sounds like bigger issues
so i i ripped one here and i was like oh
[ __ ] i'm sorry i'm
i'm in jk news right now yeah prove it
we know
she knows we know so many times
anyway let's talk about this story so
uh let's say bart and joe
i always do that joe and bart because i
looked at him when i said bart
warrior you guys make a a
a company called jk no you make
a baby deal a pact
a promise a handshake promise okay
like this one like your penises are like
this as well oh
that feels good and you tell each other
you tell each other hey man
you and i we're gonna be buying lottery
tickets
and if one of us wins we're gonna split
it down
we did that remember we did that with
all of us yeah and we're just like we're
gonna win
we all lost yeah but
but i think that was different because
we actually went in the pool yeah
the money went in one thing and then we
picked this is like just two
transactions like two people is just
like hey i'm gonna do my own thing you
do your own thing but if we win
we're gonna split it a life long so
honor system honor system yeah and
and can you believe that these two
friends they made this pact
28 years ago and one of the
guys actually won he won 22 million
dollars oh my god
and he said [ __ ] you go to hell he's
actually
making good on this wow that's a good
friend
there's good in this world because i was
thinking that
the news would have been much much
better if he says
[ __ ] you that's mine yeah i was waiting
for like a lawsuit yeah i was waiting
for her so are they still friends though
because like you know sometimes you fall
out of friendship with people you know
oh i would i would say that that voids
the contract
if you fall out of friendship yeah
because if it's like yo we're gonna do
this right
fast forward you guys drift away in
college
he wants to hang out with the boat crap
you want to hang out with a skater crowd
and he drifted away some more he's a
[ __ ] wall street guy
you're a [ __ ] hipster i'll call that
person i'd be like i know
that you're a wall street guy now and
i'm a hipster but if i
split my lotto with you are we going to
be friends for life or not
oh oh you're going to call it you're
going to call them on it
yeah it's like we better be best friends
because now we're honoring
an old friend tradition i'll be like
damn you
that [ __ ] was voided after you ditched
me
oh this i was like you that [ __ ] got
void
that contract was void when you decided
to go with carson and stacy
to the boat [ __ ] party [ __ ] and you
didn't invite me
yes boy you don't have to pay me but if
you did that honor
will go to our [ __ ] children oh
what's up and then the kids are like i
want to be friends with those kids damn
it
i give it to my own kids that's type
that is that is real strong
lawyers they not become friends and then
they're like
call 10 10 years later remember that
that'd be tough
that would be even a better story but i
actually don't know their entire
friendship history all i know is that
they made this
this pact back in 1992.
you know lannister always pays their
debts yup even when they hate them
true exactly so
here though these two friends they uh
they got interviewed so i'm going to
play a video clip
92 1992. oh that helps though sorry i
just saw
kind of what they learned that kind of
helps i'm sorry i'm a judge earlier i
i don't know that's a long wisconsin is
where this takes place
what i mean is that when you're older
maybe you don't you know what i'm saying
no what are you saying yeah and you're
already like
oh i just made after my entire life now
i'm suddenly really really rich it's
like am i really going to spend all that
or
is it better to spend it what about my
time
they made money too and they're just
like [ __ ] i don't care
what if they're they're like in their
40s i know
that lady on the right is not in her 40s
no matter what
they look they look like in their 60s if
the ladies there's no way if they're in
the 70s we're aging well
i actually don't know if they're in
their 40s they need to get a refund
on life
[Laughter]
okay anyway let's play this video clip
that they look like they're in their 60s
and they all look retired my experience
when i read them
first two or three numbers and i kind of
froze and handed them to her
and she froze and i said are you jerking
my bomber
yeah we're gonna split it so we lie
every week
that happened many years ago it just
kind of continued i'm almost 20 i think
dancing payments
i got grandchildren great i'm a company
spend time with them while worrying
about
if i got time to go and where we can go
and afford it and whatever
i can't think of i love this royalty
free song right now
the diy song ding ding ding ding ding
handshake's a handshake but in another
video there's like i [ __ ] hate chinks
i'm just kidding
when you watch videos it's always no
matter how good or how bad it's just the
slice of that person in that second
but you don't know of all the times you
beat the guy you just made this
invisible slice
you know what i mean yeah and now i
can't get that slice out of my head
i just kidding that guy was a racist
just kidding now he's a nice guy
he's an ice cream it makes it funny
because they're so sweet and then you
just
destroy their image yeah yeah nice sweet
easy
so funny that's [ __ ] honorable though
man so he
ended up deciding to take
the lump sum option lumpy
oh for sure right
never get the payout they're each gonna
receive a 5.7 million dollar
payout after federal and state taxes
that is beautiful they take a lot if you
win the lotto
if you win the lotto in like delaware or
nevada or something like that
are you not taxed on the state same
thing i don't know
the taxes might be different because
state winnings
are different different taxing like
category
oh are they winnings yeah yeah it's
still income
isn't it just capital gains regardless
like stocks
it's not capital gains unless it's after
uh 12 months
who knows yeah yeah but it's it's the
math all
it comes out to be almost like fifty
percent all the time yeah that's my
money
yeah because that was what 11 uh no 22
million right yeah 5.7 5.7 so it's like
about 11 mil 11 point something so all
these lotteries that are winning
the [ __ ] government is also winning
the lottery yeah that's why they do the
government lotteries
so why the [ __ ] are they why are [ __ ]
getting fixed they're when the
governments win the lottery every day
yeah i think everyone always remembers
yeah where does like lotto money go
because it's so crazy dude every [ __ ]
day
god damn it everyone buying a ticket in
hopes of winning
that's why they started i think the
government lottery like they they uh
that's how they make money it's also not
that much money on the government scale
like 11 million dollars but what if
they're a tiny ass like six million like
boys out idaho or some [ __ ] like ten
why don't you guys just start throwing
like a jk news lotto 50 50 raffle you
remember when at basketball games in
high school
they would always do like the 50 50
raffle what is that okay so
literally in between games or whatever
they would just come down
with a bucket and a raffle roll right
and you would go to these pep rallies
and then you'd be like raffle
two bucks yeah right and you buy a
ticket for two bucks
and then at the half time they would
pull out the winning ticket and you
would get fifty percent
of the earnings and then fifty 50 states
of the fundraising pep rally wow
it was very simple it's a very simple
transaction it makes sense
in a lot of ways i'm totally saying jk
news raffle
every episode i always wanted every
episode you pay one dollar if you want
to win
i really want a casino i really do fifty
percent
i heard that the luxor might be going
under i i wanna buy it
i still never got to ride the the
elevator that goes sideways oh yeah me
neither
you it's that place smells like
cigarettes pyramid
oh oh diagonally yeah it's it's [ __ ]
you're gonna write and be like this
[ __ ] [ __ ] i still want to write
it you know what used to be cool though
when i was a little kid
the luxor um the way you checked in
was like you put your like uh [ __ ]
bags like in a in a canal thingy
like on a boat and it goes and like what
yeah it's like a floater
yeah but they did it they took it out
because it takes like two hours to check
in and all that
forever the boat get all these chinese
people coming off the bus
like god does taste so long man what the
hell
that's hilarious oh i want a casino so
bad
cambodia is good i like gambling
cambodia
yeah the land of cambodia yeah but
inside cambodia
is a casino yeah do you want to go to
casino
and then all the chips are your coins
yeah
yeah because the other one was a patreon
video yeah it's not slot machine [ __ ]
machines
do you guys think i should make the
jamalia coin
hold on no that's not [ __ ] focused
it has face focus on there's no there's
no autofocus is there dude
you need to do the beauty it's the
beauty thingy does that work guys i
can't see
you gotta try this on your monitor yeah
there we go let me see that oh it's
working it's working
you gotta zoom in via a separate device
there we go all right am i just getting
tiff right now
there you go are we getting there do i
need a tap it's too bright
too bright oh i need to zoom in yes
knock down the brightness okay i need to
zoom in
knock down the brightness i got it are
you trying to zoom in on my chest or
something just kidding
that'll sell the coin so i get in there
am i getting there yeah [ __ ] this
no it's a josino
i want to get into jewelry too i always
like jewelry
i want to build jerry these are all the
mobster things yeah i do
without being a mobster yeah i'd be a
part of like the armenian like mafia
jewelry ring out here in downtown l.a
yeah
because it seems very organized and like
semi-non-violent
i don't know what's going on but it
seems very clean and organized yeah i
just like think
it's just i would just rather i'm just
no violent i don't know that's scary i
don't want to be in the violent world
you can't it's called business part of
the
entire you don't have to do it you just
hire people yes third-party violent
sectors yeah
why do you gotta kill you know what i
mean i'm okay you have to get your hands
dirty well that's why you gotta be like
the minority
person in the infiltration kind of like
ben affleck
as the accountant ah you know so if i
was like the asian guy in the armenian
mafia
there would be like certain just kind of
like you know swagger that comes
oh he's he's third party he's a
foreigner so you can't different
jurisdictions no because then you'll be
the most
like the easiest one to pluck because
it's like oh they're not really
yeah but in every single fbi photo you
only get this part of me
[Laughter]
you know
it's easy hello guys thank you guys so
much for watching all of our videos and
i know it's been a million years
in the making but we finally got just
kidding news
merch yup so make sure you go down to
the store below
and you can run around around yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
you